le stade français le racing réunis sur
le terrain du sky rugby à maurepas
impossible me direz vous pourtant
confronté à un manque criant de
structures toutes les équipes du stade
français ne peuvent pas évoluer à
domicile obligés d'emprunter des
terrains en région parisienne lors des
matchs prétendu à la maison une
situation qui ne perturbe pas les
stadistes
au moins ça fait un challenge qu'on joue
tout le temps l'extérieur beaucoup moi
on n'a pas d'excusés on peut gagner à la
maison comme extérieur donc au moins y'a
pas cette pression il ya moins de
pression on voit regard l'extérieur
quand je pense que les derniers sont
entrés très fort au niveau de la tête
ils ont sont capable justement de faire
des nos matchs à ce moment était
dernièrement donc là c'est quand même
très intéressant là sur cette faille
pour le style rugby haute d'un week-end
le plaisir est aussi de revoir les
jeunes formés au club évoluer à nouveau
sur le prix la première des joies ses
devoirs nos propres jeunes qui ont été
formés au club batailler avec loyauté
avec envie sur ce terrain de maurepas
dans le cadre de ces deux rencontres où
y'a que le stade français à la baguette
du club parisien jeunes saint quentinois
damien agneaux il a intégré le stade
français à 14 ans aspirant au centre de
formation c'est la saison de tous les
défis pour le jeune demi d'ouverture
mais son objectif reste le même
prendre du plaisir et aller le plus loin
possible tout en gardant les pieds sur
terre je suis en alternance en plomberie
en sap et puis on verra par la suite si
je peux rentrer au centre de formation
du stade français je me lancerai plus
sur le rugby et j'arrêterai puis si je
sois que je continue à être un peu moins
auteur d'un très bon match
il devra rééditer cette performance tous
les week-ends pour transformer cet essai
pour la petite histoire le stade
français a battu le racing sur le score
de 17 7